welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and Paramount Pictures
released Transformers rise of the Beast
teaser trailer around the same time as
Indiana Jones and the Guardians of the
Galaxy and all those Comic-Con
brazilities there's holy smokes this
movie looks wild this will be the
seventh installment to the Transformers
franchise and first in the plan Trilogy
though this movie features care ERS
characters from the 96 TV show Beast
Wars it follows up from the late
in 2018 and that took place in the 80s
this movie will take place approximately
in 1994. so you know I had to jump on
this bad boy jump on the opportunity to
break it down with my best friend in the
entire universe Tommy Bechtel yes
Jessica my girl move over little Hammer
Olympics 1994's got a new signature
event and it's the Beast Wars Jessica
much like these robots I can't keep my
excitement in Disguise any longer this
trailer has to be hyped to get back into
a world that kind of put on the geek
back burner I feel like a lot of people
might have done that because the
characters have ranged from so many
different types and different points of
view you guys I love the Transformer
movies but I didn't spend a lot of time
watching the animated shows so this was
super fun to go through and to go
through all of the live action movies
that I watch and we will be breaking
this trailer down scene by scene to make
sure we hit everything that you might
have missed let's just get into it let's
go roll out
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
there is a Darkness coming
we open it what I
was in Brooklyn New York and Peru we're
introduced to the enormous metal gorilla
AKA leader of the maximals Optimus
primal voiced by Ron Perlman who's also
voice Optimus primal in the Transformers
power of the primes this is the second
time doing it as Optimus Prime kind of
like led the Autobots Optimus primal
leads the maximals during B stores the
maximals were descendants of the
Autobots in 2300 so the relationship
goes beyond having similar ranks
basically you see optimal Prime as
Optimus Prime he just transforms into a
gorilla we also see Optimus Prime who
needs no introduction uh I mentioned his
name a million times this is the face of
those Transformers for years our Numero
Uno voiced by Peter color I love it how
lucky are we to still have that guy
doing the voice
exactly hell yeah you're doing it good
buddy great job the two Folks at the
bottom between the two are Elena Dominic
Fishback and Noah who's Anthony Ramos oh
yes well Hamilton or uh in the Heights
or in the hood
yeah right
from Iron Heart you said oh how dare you
say that to me I'm sorry uh Primal warns
Optimus Prime there is a Darkness coming
now if Primal is from the future this
teases the chance he's coming from the
future to warm Prime of what's about to
go down which we're about to get into
more on the trailer
whoever I'm not driving
[Applause]
it opens with a slightly remixed of
juicy by Biggie Smalls it was all a
dream for me okay but it's got like a
mechanical beat but it was all the
dreams that's exactly what you would
imagine like for a movie like this would
be people are going to clip that out and
show it a nerd I am
and we're back in Brooklyn stand up baby
or rather roll out because my boy
Optimus Prime is rolling out in this
classic big rig fit across the Brooklyn
Bridge heard of it pretty famous
structure bumblebee is also back in his
classic Camaro Glory this movie is like
we said a sequel to 2018's Bumblebee
which are prequels to the Michael Bay
Transformer movies I know it's all
confusing now we saw our yellow friend
glow up from a punch buggy to a muscle
car that's what I'm talking about you
know what I mean you got to put a little
mask makes a big gains in the automobile
category we see that our aforementioned
human protagonist Noah get behind the
wheel of a Porsche which we will soon
discover is the Autobot Mirage voiced by
the irresistible first of all Pete
Davidson I'm so excited to see what this
voice is going to look like for this
character I gotta say too like Pete
Davidson interacting with Anthony Ramos
as a car that is in control antagonizing
I think Ramos a bit will definitely be
very funny now Mirage in Transformers in
the generation one cartoon the ability
to turn invisible but in this film he
gets a massive power up by gaining the
ability to create these holographic
duplicates of himself which we see in
the trailer yeah so let's listen to a
little bit more of it
it's the broken way
we see Mirage split into four additional
look-alike cars creating the ultimate
illusion like Tommy said earlier one of
mirage's abilities consists of creating
these Illusions which we've seen in the
comics and we've seen in TV series so
this isn't actually too far off from his
normal abilities throughout every
franchise product he's been in we're
introduced to an off-roading bumblebee
speeding alongside the sickest maximum
in my opinion you guys this is cheetor
huge
I love cheater
it's like when you
[Music]
clearly based off a cheetah is seen as
the young one of the maximals ready to
play and fight as soon as possible which
also makes sense why in this scene we
see him teamed up with bumblebee we jump
to this huge falcon-like maximal who's
air razor voiced by Michelle yo air
razor like a falcon is basically the
eyes of the operation she was super
funny red fighting at times over
confident in the animated series and
she's gonna be seen belting Flames so
she's going to be fast right gave me
some Game of Thrones Vibes with that
flame streak also uh air razor is one of
the of the few maximals that is very
closely bonded with their animal form
because in the cartoon when she comes
down to earth she's injured and she
takes the form of a falcon as a way of
healing from her damage that she took as
an Autobot as an ancient as a maximum
very exciting for me is she your
favorite well I mean anything Michelle
yo does moves up my priority I'm like yo
oh my God he's going off that horrible
ten thousand parties
um this truck that we see shooting a
missile is actually battle trap they
confirmed in an interview he'll be
playing the tow truck and we'll get into
that a little bit more in the trailer
when we see a more clear image of him
fully transformed we later see RC she's
holding on to the Volkswagen van which
is actually real Jack wheel Jack we saw
it in the Michael Bay's movies as was
just this insane like old kooky Autobot
so now we got with Jack I think we also
got an image of Wheeljack in Bumblebee
and like the opening sequence where he's
very dignified so we've got the
dignified we've got the Doc Brown now
we're getting kind of like a Volkswagen
Bug I love it Wheeljack changes so much
and this is probably something I think
we're all hoping to see because not a
lot of people were actually excited
about a lot of the looks that wheel Jack
has had bigger Transformer sounds
awesome right well if you want to
transform from somebody who doesn't know
anything about wine into somebody who
can impress your friends by showing up
to a holiday party with the perfect gift
of burgundy then you gotta check out
bright sellers bright sellers is the
easiest way for people who are curious
about wine to learn what kind of wines
they love so they can share their love
of wine with the people they love and
trust me if you're like me you know
nothing about wine you educate yourself
you lie your little pants off at a party
and people are like what a dignified men
right sellers has you take a quick seven
question quiz that will match you with
wines from all over the world pick
specifically to match your tastes after
that bright sellers will send the wine
directly to you so you don't have to
waste time at the liquor store buying
wines based off the label each package
and comes with a wine education card for
every bottle that outlined tasting notes
suggested pairings and best serving
temperatures let me tell you a white
wine with a Chilean sea bass no way
right sellers they sent me a tinderella
De Luna from Italy the info card
suggested a beautiful piece of white
fish and that was spot on me personally
I could do it with a Snickers bar but
I'm not classy easily a new go-to wine
for me if you rate your wines after you
try them your future picks will improve
so you can dial in exactly what type of
wine you like if you've got follow-up
questions write sellers concierge team
will help you with any questions you
might have like how do you open wine can
I just have a screw top no you can't
learn how to use a corkscrew you're an
adult bright sellers is giving our
followers a limited time offer fifty
dollars off their first six bottle box
click the link in the description to get
started you'll be so glad you did you'll
be so glad you did transform yourself
out of being a simp learn about wine oh
take it away Jessica and Tommy from the
future going back to RC normally RC
could be seen as pink but in the
animated series or suit is sort of red
so we're assuming that she's based it
off of that look RC is a fighter great
with guns hand-to-hand combat you name
it as the female Transformer they
basically made her for young girls who
love Transformers so back in the day you
could kind of see her as a mom figure
caring and supportive and everyone just
loved her she's based on Princess Leia
with the Buns included and RC was last
seen in bumblebee in that quick stunt at
the very beginning and she's going to be
boys by Liza kosher you're telling me
there's a pathway for YouTubers to
become voices of Transformers lizac
bless you see Jessica and I as skid mark
and whatever that other one was we're
gonna be in the in the reboot we're
gonna be like here we go
ripped apart by Megatron I'm into that
and like Tommy said earlier with wheel
Jack he was in the Bumblebee movie at
the very beginning he was um in Dark of
the Moon as the very old old man robot
he had tiny little glasses he was like
Albert he was like Albert Einstein he
was very rickety and he didn't have the
best ending but he's coming back in this
he's gonna be the W van that's right
guys in that movie sorry for the
interruption
hey come on then we came out eight years
okay he's gonna be playing the VW van
and he will be voted by Cristo Fernandez
Bill Jack and RC's relationship also is
one of like true friendship truly they
really do need each other because they
differ so much in personality but
they're basically the same like the same
same head of the coin same how do you
say two sides of the same coin two sides
of the same coin uh they're both the
lone wolves they're both head strong and
supportive of each other when needed so
this chemistry that we're seeing of them
on the bridge might actually be
something to look forward to that's
basically Us by the way incredible let's
look at some more of this trailer of all
the threats
from both your past
and future
you've never faced anything like this
let them come things are taking a little
turn for the ominous here as Optimus
primal warns and a voiceover of all the
threats from both your past and future
you've never faced anything like this
all right and as we hear that we see the
main villain from the movie I believe
scored voiced by Peter Dinklage impaling
Bumblebee with a sword Scourge is a huge
villain in the Transformers Universe but
we have yet to see him on the big screen
in one of the Animated Series Scourge is
actually a clone of Optimus Prime but in
this movie he does take the form of a
semi truck although he looks a lot more
like a semi truck from the Mad Max world
than one from our world his robot form
doesn't really look like Prime at all so
I don't think that's going to be what
this story is now in another iteration
of the comics in cartoon Scourge was
created by Unicron one of the big bads
in the Transformers Universe a world
eating robot planet that we first met in
Transformers the motion picture Unicron
was teased after the last Michael Bay
verse Transformers movie Transformers
The Last Knight and that quote seems to
visually imply that it's about Scourge
but I think it's actually leading to an
all-out confrontation between Autobots
and Unicron in the next movie
trilogy this is the start of it yes I
think it's much like Thanos we're going
to Slow Burn on Unicron here next we see
a celebration I'm not 100 what this is
but I did a little research you know I
love holidays and parades my best guess
is it's the Cusco Cusco Corpus Christi
celebration in Peru honoring the Holy
Eucharist it's one of the biggest
celebrations in Peruvian culture and it
includes a huge parade with marching
bands and color guard as we can see in
this image so that's my best guess we
also get a look at rhinox roaring in his
rhinoceros form in the cartoons Rolex
was a bit of a science nerd but he looks
like a pure Brute Force enforcer in this
clip you know what I'm saying rhinox is
thick he's a thick boy we then see three
asteroids Landing in the water around
New York City which is bad for the
asteroids in the water because neither
one are clean the three asteroids
Landing in the water are most likely to
films three villains Scourge battle trap
and night bird fingers crossed nightbird
has nunchucks like in the cartoon where
she's kind of a ninja weirdly oh my God
I'm so into this okay let's watch a
little bit more
foreign
Optimus Prime says can you say it let
them come he's so good at it and we've
taken to this battlefield you guys this
is our yellow blasting Terracon battle
trap who we know from the same interview
will be playing the tow truck so battle
trap and flywheels could combine to be a
two vehicle robot yes we don't know if
we're going to see flywheels though we
don't know yet now battle trap allegedly
said this says on his actual card will
show it right here like to trap his foe
between his Jeep and helicopter vehicles
and have fun with them knock them back
and forth a bit before finally
destroying them he's a True Villain you
guys we don't know if we'll see
flywheels yet but it would be cool to
see the duocon he's voiced by David
sobelov who plays ryanox as well wow yes
oh my God I just love these little
pieces these are the parts from King
Kong from Godzilla that I just love so
much the ultimate fights where there's
no humans involved we see cheat or
transforming the sick flip in Optimus
Prime and what might be the sickest
thing I've ever seen in a Transformers
trailer Optimus Prime all transforming
from his gorilla form this Clash is
Ultimate and is just going to be my
favorite part of the movie and I can't
wait I gotta say I loved it in this
trailer that the maximals still have
like fur even when they're robots yeah
Optus Primal doesn't have the blue and
red that he used to have to kind of
indicate that he's a prime he looks so
badass in this and like who even cares
and when he transforms what I really
like is like he's a gorilla yes we get
that bony transforms he still has that
gorilla-like features where he's like
I'm a maximal but he's like running like
this yes and I'm like yes
I know so let's get into some more of
this trailer all right
[Music]
and much like us our human protagonist
Elena is out of breath and she's sitting
in a fetal position rocking back and
forth saying this can't be real well our
autobot RC voiced again as we said by
Liza koshy gives her a polite wave a
funny moment of levity in an absolutely
action-packed trailer and then we end
with the hero shot baby Noah and Mirage
doing the hero walk towards the camera
in slow motion let me tell you who's not
gonna be in slow motion Tommy Beck told
when this movie opens I will be
sprinting rolling out to the theater as
soon as this movie opens maybe like this
you think this is the one part where
humans come in that I do enjoy do you
think RC is gonna belong belong to uh
Dominic fishback's character Elena I
think they're gonna Bond I mean that's
kind of what we get in the Transformers
movies is like a bond you know we had
the wiki family bonding with the primes
and and Bumblebee being a caretaker I
think those two are are interconnected
because I think that we Dominique
fishback's character seems to be kind of
panicked and frightened and I think RC
as we said is motherly yeah Princess
Leia like comforting she's a princess to
me she's royalty to me she's royalty you
guys let me know in the comments let us
both know in the comments what you
thought on Transformers rise of the
Beast follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at Lulu underscore Clemons well Tommy at
Tommy bech told right yeah yes and
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
Rockstar guys for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
Autobots roll out
I'm stuck
[Music]